he's fresh off of beaten Alabama he's a
tours around back here in the Rich Eisen
show how are you coach well you know
what I'm better for talking to you coach
I'll be very honest with you
very honestly I just want I just want to
get some sort of sense from you a few
days later what this win means for you
in the program you small football
players they have worked very hard to
beat Alabama you sort of state of
Louisiana eight years we had to here and
every time I went to a convenience store
or grocery store got gas coach you got a
beat Alabama force so I just felt proud
for the state of Louisiana and profile
football players and all the players
that are played here before and you come
off the plane and there's the Governor
John bel Edwards extended as a mean I
trade off the flow chart there coach
there
LSU means a lot to the state of
Louisiana the governor's one of our
biggest fans Shores is white they have a
great family with close friends and
bindhi thousands of people wait for the
airport well but appreciative of that
yeah we saw the video of Boro going down
the line through the chain-link fence
and and he has just obviously taken the
opportunity that you afforded him a
couple of years ago and run with it when
did he first appear on your radar screen
coach yeah well we were looking for a
graduate transfer quarterback
bill Bush who was at Ohio State you that
he was going to transfer so we started
in the right way trying to get in touch
with Joe when he if we could get in
touch with him we record and brought
them over here and worked out thank God
yeah sure did and what did you realize
about him the first time you you got him
on a practice field intelligence first
time about wait a minute football
meeting Joe was so smart he's a coach's
son very intelligent and then when he
came on the practice field we had a 60
110 run he won every one he was very
competitive kept his mouth shut
work hard and under respect to the team
and order on here on the
chosen show and now so much being made
of the offense that passing coordinator
Joe Brady has brought in from I guess in
a way the New Orleans Saints or is there
any concern on your part about injecting
that into the system mater mater I knew
what we needed to do
I knew the players that we had when
athletes or to put him his face we had a
quarterback he is see there's we're
gonna put together a tremendous
offensive believe it amount was just
getting started so when you said you
knew what you had to do walk me through
that what what did you have to do based
on what you were seeing from your
program score points to score points to
beat down the balance to beat the
Georgia's to beat the Florida's we had
to go to spread offense put athletes in
space and give them the ball and let me
talk to you about a couple things here
first things first couple times I'm
sitting at home during that game alright
and I'm thinking they got to take the
air out of the ball and then you got you
know Edwards a layer running it so well
it was so difficult to stop him but your
offenses no chill I mean you're you're
snapping the ball with like 30 seconds
left on the play clock coach you're not
sitting there thinking let's let's take
the air out of ball a little bit no we
got a score points we know getting
school points in this league especially
when they have a quarterback like to us
and the receivers that they had they can
strike as we seen anywhere in the field
we're gonna keep the pedal to the metal
the whole game but I mean the pedal to
the metal can also be snapped at like
ten five seconds right I mean you put
that all together and you're leaving
like a minute left on the clock for
someone like you even as a scorer but we
also we felt like we had to score more
points well you put up 46 in Tuscaloosa
which somebody nobody's done since 1907
Edwards you're on LSU head coach here on
the Rich Eisen show what about Joe
Brady's future so much is being
discussed already even though he's under
contract for two more years where does
that where does that conversation stand
well we all know Joe has a bright future
we'll keep them here as long as we can
we're gonna compete for we know other
people gonna come after him over already
talk to them
but right now Joe Brady he's in there he
doesn't have a phone he's looking at old
missus coverages and wanting to beat Ole
Miss that's the type of coach he is well
in terms of moving on and keeping things
going and I guess shutting out all the
praise and the noise that does come with
being number one overall off a big win
Nick Saban calls that rat poison I'm
wondering if you have a term for it
coach I called a block out the noise go
out that tweeting machine block out the
noise but the way we get to work is
today is turnover Wednesday we're going
to focus in on our practice today focus
on getting better from yesterday
focusing on the fundamentals and I do
believe we have great leadership a great
coaching team to get the job done so
wait a minute because our last
conversation that we had coach you said
that there was tell the truth Monday at
Ellis correct okay right so now there's
what is Wednesday what is Wednesday
called turnover wisdom yes it was
competition Tuesday okay so oh I thought
it was Taco Tuesday there's no time oh I
guess it's not a down in Cajun country
so okay so so it's much it's tell the
truth Monday um competition Tuesday and
then turn to everyone's what's Thursday
no repeat Thursday okay and then focus
Friday and then Saturday's game day yep
and Sunday is just chillax Sunday what
is Sunday so what truth was told Monday
did were there any month did you did
you'd buy we tell the truth Monday this
past Monday yeah yeah well the truth was
it was a great team win but we didn't
play at LSU standard performance for 60
minutes and we still have a ways to go
to get to the team that we want to be
mm-hmm
and and you know I say this is you know
I feel like we have a rapport coach and
and you take this in the right way it
does seem though that it could have been
tell the truth Saturday based on some of
the video we heard from your speech to
the team
I wish I'd stayed and helped but you
know you get emotion about the game like
that I know
so what emotions were flowing through
you to say what we all heard you say
well you know you used to get fiery
speeches or sometimes you say thank
within the family yeah you expected the
stands and inside the family is a dress
that I should have never get out that
was not better form anybody and now that
was not that for the public that was
just meant for football team right and
now did you speak to the young man who
has I guess to use your phrase took to
the tweeter machine to do to say
something like that huh sure he made a
mistake in the understand and we move
forward from it okay and let's be honest
though I mean Alabama kind of feels the
same way about you right wouldn't you
say that is a great answer I'll be very
very honest with you so there's a lot of
conversation to about borrow and I do
want to just put a pin in that to
revisit and a couple minutes that we
have left and I want to focus on this
kid from Baton Rouge that runs the
football for you primarily number 22
Clyde Edwards a layer what an amazing
performance this kid put on tape with
the whole country watch and also that's
for the future but for the moment for
your program what does it mean for you
to have a kid from Baton Rouge do that
walk me through your relationship with
him I had a chance to recruit guy to
have a great relationship with him Clyde
has tremendous character and heart he's
a team leader he's a unselfish player
but he's very driven very driven in a
lot of ways I thought everybody with
Clyde it was a lair walks in the room
he's 64 to 70 that's the type of
personality and mindset he has I'm so
happy for him and his family and do you
tell the kids before the game I mean I
talked to Brad Nessler who called the
game and he gave me a little bit of a
hint here do you talk to your kids about
the next level saying in a game like
this the scouts are gonna be watching
more than ever I mean we've had mike
Mayock my colleague from the NFL Network
now with the Raiders we had also last
week
from from ESPN Todd McShea they're
saying that's the first tape they put on
when they're gonna evaluate is this game
LSU Alabama do you bring that and Brooks
that subject with your players you know
I think we talked to it don't
individually we may talk to them as a
position coach but as a head coach I
just talked to him about the team and
what we have to do well but I do know as
a position coach I would use that as a
motivation okay and it's it true that
some of your players went up to recruits
that were there for Alabama and told
them after the game wanted you to check
us out is that true stories that happen
[Laughter]
we're all just paying rent in your world
right now and then last thing for you on
borrow the converse the words you know
it's interesting you're passing
coordinators name is Joe Brady
because that is a nickname a lot of
people are using right now because of
how cool and calm and collected your
quarterback looks and distributing the
football knowing where it should go pre
snap and delivering it post snap like
Tom Brady do you think that that is a
fair or accurate comparison at origin
Ron you know for what I see on TV a lot
of uptown now I don't know him
personally but I know the women that he
has and go to some big shoes to fill but
Joe is on Tom Brady he does a great job
for us we believed in them coach Oh
Congrats on the Big W I'd love to chat
with you just as often as we have during
this season so look for my phone call
one more time thank you my friend
don't Tigers you got etc for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app